happiness isn't just about what
medication you're on it also depends on
where you live the world happiness
report for 2015 is out published by the
sustainable development solutions
Network the survey attempts to measure
the happiness of citizens across 158
countries
so a lot of Western countries there I
know countries in the West seem to get a
lot of [ __ ] these days but I guess we're
doing something right in the happiness
Department maybe it's because we're
making countries in the what in the East
unhappy i'm not sure but let's start
with number 15 the united states does
that seem about right to you guys as
Americans do you feel like we're roughly
that seems ballpark yeah we're
moderately happy yeah is there any
chance we could ever be as happy as the
people in Switzerland I mean isn't that
like the thing like they don't get
involved in anything really so and
they're very homogeneous society so it's
like there's a certain level of
happiness that maybe we just can't get
to uh have you thought of that maybe
that's why they're number one and we're
down there towards the end yeah yeah
they don't start any wars they eat a lot
of chocolate so it's chocolate little
war yeah what else what else would be
the keys chocolate no words those have
you uh yeah just how beautiful the
location is tearing you know like um I I
think sometimes people need to learn how
to be happy I think it's an important
thing you know like meditation I nose is
very seeing a sort of Renaissance these
days you know i just i think that uh for
many people it's just something that
eludes them because they're just too
much you know caught in the moment and
they're not you know they don't know how
to be mindful and grateful for what they
have yeah let's throw the image backup
for just a second David what do you make
of the fact that these are mostly
westernized countries so we're not in
all your travels was there some where
you went where you that's not on this
list that you think that the people
might be happier and also of course we
all gauge happiness differently yeah so
I'm not a hundred percent sure of the
scientific basis yeah it's interesting
i'd love to know how they gauge this but
i often find that the places i go in the
developing world the people seem happier
and that sounds terrible because we also
we always associate a freak for example
with poverty and there are people living
in extremely difficult conditions but
when you look at people how they live
their in their family unit i often see
people's just level of joy being with
always with their family living in
tight-knit communities that's real
happiness as far as i'm concerned i see
it a lot in developing countries so i
don't know how they come up with that
list but if I had to gauge list places
like Senegal in Africa the people there
to me see
happier than Swiss people for example
yeah it's really interesting and I guess
that's the catch-22 of westernized
civilization like we get all these
gadgets right we have all of our iphones
and all that stuff but is any of this
stuff making us any happier do you think
that all this technology that we have
and this interconnectivity do you think
it's making us happy right yeah I don't
think I mean obviously things you can't
buy happiness you know the time that
I've spent abroad in Europe and things
like that I think people tend to spend
their money more on experiences and that
I think is something that not we don't
necessarily appreciate here in the
States yeah much does it all come down
low to what you're saying about like the
family unit i was in el salvador two
years ago it's a true third-world
country I mean they literally don't have
they have garbage that they're burning
on the street because they don't have
trash pickup but the people there all
did seem relative they were poor but
they did seem pretty happy actually yeah
I think it's a difference between
happiness and joy maybe I don't know how
to define it but there is something
there that we don't experience yeah
maybe its loneliness versus happiness
here we're just we're consumed by our
devices like you said and we sort of
find solace in our iphones and there
it's like you're you're with your
friends all the time you're running
around on the street you having fun I
don't know but maybe there's a
correlation with the coldness I've
noticed that the top countries are seem
very cold how does that make any sense
I'm not a good guy hence I live in Los
address but yeah Switzerland Iceland
Denmark Norway Canada yeah they're all
the top of the world's very bizarre
bazaar wait where it's so Australia
number 10 Israel Middle East so there
it's warm over there but Wow anyway what
do you think are you happy where are you
watching this right now and does that
make any sense to you let us know in the
comments right now